you and Roy Nelson were the security at  Spearmint Rhino yeah who the [ __ ] can  you imagine like hey get out of here I'm  not going anywhere like security and  then you and Roy [ __ ] Nelson show up  that was true yeah oh really that's true  he actually worked a different shift  than I did because that would help his  training and stuff I work the night  shifts because you know I was the most  money and didn't really care about  getting good sleep so I mean up till uh  2008 I would work four nights a week  that's nuts work from you know 9 pm to 5  a.m I would take the week off before I  went to fight so even when I fought for  the UFC title when I fought uh Tim  Silvio I literally worked up until  that's right nuts dude and then the week  before the fight took that weekend off  to try to get my sleep schedule fixed so  I wasn't such a you know uh yeah a night  owl yeah and then as soon as I would  fight I would next weekend I was back at  work